hey guys I'm Abby char welcome to Abby's
kitchen so ever since I reviewed freelee
the banana girls would eat in a day I've
gotten a lot of requests from all you
guys for other youtubers diets to review
so today I want to share with you a
little review of Ellen Fischer's what
ate in a day so Ellen and her kids live
in Maui Hawaii which looks pretty
amazing and her and her family all
uphold a plant-based diet so great to
raise your kids vegan but of course
there are some considerations and
adjustments that need to be made to be
making sure that we're doing it in a
nutritionally balanced way so let's take
a look at Ellen's what eight in a day
so first of all those kids are adorable
and big kudos to Ellen for getting her
kids involved in the kitchen I think
that is a fantastic and very important
life skill but I'm not a fan of big
quantities of juice for children I mean
I think what from what I can see it
looks like her son is really really into
just snacking on the whole foods himself
so I don't really know why Ellen
wouldn't just let him do that and just
serve that as a snack
it would probably save her a lot of time
and probably a lot of money as well so I
get that a lot of parents think this is
the only way to get in all those
vitamins and minerals but when we're
juicing we're losing out on a lot of
those really important fibers so if
you're going to go the juice route you
definitely want to keep it to no more
than like a quarter cup for a young
child that looks like a lot more than a
quarter cup so that would be my big
concern and you know don't just throw
away that pulp
I saw her kind of skimming it off or or
straining the juice all that pulp has
the fiber and so what you would want to
do with that pulp is maybe shirt into
yogurt or oats or you can dehydrate it
and make it into some kind of fruit and
veggie leather that'd be a really great
option so you're not wasting all that
great food
love it so I loved watching this little
kid eat with his fork he's got some
great utensil skills and I agree avocado
is definitely one of my son's favorite
foods it's a great source of
monounsaturated fats so really really
healthy for babes who are growing also I
love all the antioxidants in that papaya
looks like a really yummy combination
but I'd love to see some more variety
here in this diet ideally some source of
iron so maybe some pulses some lentils
or beans that would really help balance
this out and make it a lot more
nutritionally complete
[Applause]
so side note it looks like Ellen is just
having papaya and passion fruit for
breakfast I would love to see some
protein up in here it definitely is
reminded me a lot of our friend freelee
the banana girl but I do love how much
that Ellen really lets Andy be
independent with his food I think that
is a great skill I love that he is just
getting in there with his fork he's
doing his thing
he's self feeding he's self-regulating
and that is a really really important
feeding skill I also am loving that
they're still breastfeeding so the who
recommends continual breast feeding up
to two years of age I don't really know
how old Sandhya is exactly but I mean
kudos to you mama it is so much work I
know how hard it is so it's great that
you were keeping that up having said
that I am still worried a little bit
about the lack of iron in these meals so
let's hope that we can balance things
out throughout the rest of the day
[Music]
[Applause]
all right so it looks like lunch is a
smoothie um and again I just wish I
wasn't seeing so many liquid foods so
first at breakfast with the juice now
we've got a smoothie I mean I do like
that she added some hemp parts to the
mix and have hearts of course are gonna
add some good fats and some protein and
some fiber and some iron but again not a
whole lot else there's also some
spirulina in here which of course is
packed with nutrition there is a lot of
hype around spirulina and we don't have
a ton of research to support it but I do
think it is a really great nutritional
add in so that's fantastic but it really
does look like sandy is so interested in
enjoying like whole pieces of food so I
really would just have loved to see more
opportunities for that
[Music]
[Music]
so more avocados again
avocados super nutritious but I would
love to see some more variety in the
fats that Ellen's offering sandy also it
seems like pretty much all the foods
that Sandy's getting are like really
soft like purees or juices or smoothies
not a whole lot of variety and texture
and different things to pick up and
explore so I would have loved to see
some more options on that front also not
a fan of the addition of the sprouts
because sprouts are actually grown in a
warm environment and are often linked to
foodborne illness so they're not
recommended that we serve them to
children when they're raw so lightly
cooked sprouts would have been a better
choice for sandy so I do love that she
adds some dulse in there to get some
protein and iron but let's talk about
Sandy's overall diet for the day so
we've calculated how much nutrition
Sandy's getting in the day we does not
include the breast milk of course
because we really don't know the length
of the feeds or how often he's feeding
or how much was actually consumed but
based on what we can see it does look
like sandy is meeting his nutritional
needs for the day but I would definitely
say that his diet is far from balanced
so there are some vitamins and minerals
that may be missing or low in Sandy's
diet so let's talk about that first of
all let's talk about b12 b12 is a common
nutrient of concern for people who are
taking on a plant-based diet so I'm
really hoping that the family is
supplementing in general next the big
one that I'm concerned about is of
course iron so we really need to ensure
that we're getting enough iron in our
baby's diets especially for the
six-month mark when breast milk becomes
inadequate so I like that I saw a little
bit of iron in the seaweed that was
added to the salad and the heme parts
that was added to the smoothie
but the smoothie was shared and you know
he really probably didn't get that much
from it also there was some iron in the
color greens in the morning juice but he
probably only ate like half a cup of
that which would probably amount about
one milligram of irons
tolerance between 1-3 years actually
need around seven milligrams of iron so
I would love to see more plant-based
sources of iron like lentils tofu
broccoli and fortified cereals
so my next nutrient of concern is zinc I
would have loved to see more zinc based
foods like oats beans legumes nuts and
seeds all of which are really important
for growth and development for busy
babies and then finally let's talk about
vitamin D so because sandy is breastfed
it's recommended that you get your
vitamin D from food sources or
supplements since breast milk is low in
vitamin D so you want to look for
plant-based sources like mushrooms tofu
fortified nut milks and of course D
drops I am in no way here to shame
another mother and their family but when
I see a youtuber being out there sharing
their life and recommending to other
moms of what to feed their babies I have
to have my expertise hat on let me also
say that feeding a baby a vegan diet
absolutely can be done it just needs to
be followed carefully and all vitamins
and minerals and nutrients need to be
accounted for also there's nothing wrong
with including smoothies or the
occasional bit of juice and your kids
diets however I really think we need to
focus on getting our kids a nice variety
of different textures and consistencies
to enjoy and explore not to mention when
we juice everything we lose it on those
beneficial fibers finally I would just
like to see more variety in this kids
diet I'm sure he would love to explore
new foods and develop different oral
motor skills and also to ensure he's
getting all of the necessary nutrients
in his day so if you are considering
feeding your child a vegan diet or any
kind of restricted diet make sure that
you're speaking to a registered
dietician and coming up with a strategy
that works for both you and your family
you want to make sure you're getting
this information from a trusted
professional and not necessarily from a
youtuber so guys I hope you enjoyed this
video if you did be sure to give it the
thumbs up leave me a comment below some
youtubers what I eat in a day videos
that you'd like me to review subscribe
to the channel and I'll see you next
time on Abby's kitchen bye
[Music]